[Applaudissements]
le 3 mars 2022 une loi visant à
renforcer le contrôle parental sur les
appareils technologiques ordinateur
téléphone tablette a été publié au
Journal officiel après avoir été adopté
par le Sénat le 24 février
attends tu as voté ça papa ça veut dire
que toi Maman et d'autres adultes auront
le droit de contrôler ce que je regarde
sur mon téléphone bah merci je vais être
surveillé tout le temps je sais bien que
tu es assez grande pour décider par
toi-même ce que tu as envie de faire et
de regarder et sur Internet les enfants
et les jeunes sur les plus exposés aux
dangers des dangers lesquels le
développement de ton cerveau tes
capacités d'apprentissage ta
concentration tout ça peut être dérangé
par la surconsommation des outils
numériques ah je suis sûr qu'on disait
exactement la même chose à propos de la
télé quand tu avais mon âge exact je
m'en souviens mais pense aux risques de
fausses informations ou encore
d'exposition à des contenus hors la loi
ou cyber-harcèlement ah oui c'est vrai
tout ça ça n'existait pas avant avec ces
nouveaux dangers il faut appliquer des
mesures qui permettent d'assurer une
plus grande sécurité dans tes accès aux
réseaux et au site et il n'y a pas
d'autres solutions aujourd'hui que celle
d'un contrôle parental efficace pas pour
te traquer toi mais pour traquer les
auteurs de contenu et de messages
inapproprié ouais je comprends mais au
fait comment ça fonctionne ton fameux
contrôle parental il repose sur un
ensemble de fonctionnalités le filtrage
de contenu inapproprié l'encadrement de
ton temps d'écran des interactions et
des dépenses en ligne l'accès à
l'historique de navigation aux
conversations au compte du téléchargé à
la localisation etc ce contrôle est
paramétrable par les parents en fonction
de l'âge et de la maturité de leurs
enfants il ne faut pas qu'il devienne un
outil trop strict
mais concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va
changer cette nouvelle loi en France 82
% des enfants de 10 à 14 ans vont
régulièrement sur Internet sans leurs
parents mais seul 43% des parents ont
mis en place un contrôle parental et
bien la loi du 2 mars 2022 crée tout
simplement une obligation d'installation
d'un système parental par défaut
par exemple il est prévu mais ce n'est
pas obligatoire d'empêcher la réception
de messages de personnes extérieures au
foyer à l'exception de celle de
confiance dont les parents auront
autorisé le contact ah d'accord et puis
la loi vise à harmoniser les
fonctionnalités et les caractéristiques
techniques des outils de contrôle
parental tu vois l'objectif n'est pas de
t'interdire l'accès au réseau ni de te
traquer ni de sécuriser ton accès à ses
services au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée
nationale on reste persuadé que rien ne
remplace le dialogue familial ni
l'éducation numérique
pour en savoir plus sur le contrôle
parental rends-toi sur le site internet
Sénat junior